to sing a song in honor of my dad and I
think it was turning my sister Clarice
or something like sister Pam or
something like that and she her
rendition of Amazing Grace had my sister
and I in tears laughing I'm telling you
laughing and we did really small
apartment yeah she's like brother Edgar
we miss you I and I was so like
grief-stricken but in that moment my
sister and I like we were pinching each
other so that we wouldn't laugh but I
was holding my breath in because I was
it was the funniest thing I had ever
heard in my life she was so horrible I
mean look at kalila we go far she's calm
just let this hear what I'm saying look
out look out look how far she's come
she's getting laughs on her own great
he's taking her time she's confident she
knows that she's gonna get a laugh right
she which she commits to the [ __ ]
punch line right and look at her on the
field on Prop Island the reviews yeah
what did you text I tasted kalila no
joke not being completely serious you
[ __ ] killed it on the show [ __ ] after
all I was being myself
yeah but you know you just look at what
she's doing now she's bought out she's
not getting the confidence it's hard to
be yourself in front of camera you said
in the car there
yeah [ __ ] so now why wait a couple
years from now right she's gonna be on a
series you know we're not working oh my
god we created a monster would you
consider it though no you did a really
very good I thought it was good what did
you you were very fun what do I send you
a monkfish after you said hey you should
work for one Fc oh yeah what did I send
you back what text did I send you no I
can't cuz mags ID ID sweat oh I know but
what picture that I send you
oh you're nasty wet foot exactly it's
impossible for me to possible you look
dry very dry yeah I was nervous but if
you have a chance it's alright the
Comedy Central please watch website it's
very good man up man off so funny we did
the opening was our the opening episode
I think so there was a couple before us
only three episodes yeah anyway I'd be
getting a lot of rave reviews on it dude
you in the kid that lady was so you're
pretty good with children
yeah wow I'm good you know they get it I
mean if you I mean if you look at the
story that's pulling up together photo
with Xander jumping on me and me hugging
was like a folder that they took motive
splitting up together Instagram and
there's a photo where the youngest kid
jumps on me and we laugh right kids
generally you know I think like me right
I do because my intentions are pure
[Music]